[Musique]
parce que notre ville se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
je t'écris ces quelques lignes pour te
dire que oui je suis prêt à faire un
petit bout de chemin avec toi ps quand
je prends deux bouts de chemin je veux
dire départ de chez moi arriver au
boulot puis le retour mais aussi
possible tous les jours merci à toi le
covoiturage c'est convivial économique
et écologique avec le covoiturage saint
quentin en yvelines vous propose une
nouvelle façon de vous déplacer les
inscriptions et les infos sur
www.covoiturage.fr lotir et est-ce qu y
pourrait faire
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro d' équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable ce numéro est
consacré au patrimoine naturel autour de
saint quentin en yvelines des oiseaux
auxerre en passant par les pins et
champignons vous allez découvrir la
richesse de la faune et la flore à deux
pas de chez vous et pour commencer nous
sommes ici à l'espace rambouillet est
avec nous en compagnie de didier chago
responsable d'exploitation bonjour
bonjour merci de nous recevoir alors on
est ici donc à rambouillet on pense tout
de suite aux serres
historiquement c'est eux qui étaient là
dès le départ c'est le patrimoine
naturel c'est un des patrimoines naturel
de cet endroit c'est le cers la forêt
d'embrouillés est une fort exr c'est une
forêt de chasse une forêt de vénerie
depuis fort longtemps depuis louis xiv
et bien au delà même c'était un terrain
de chasse royale c'était un tarot de
chasse royale entre autres avant il ya
une autre d'autres propriétaires
d'autres seigneurs mais ça a été unifiée
en gros à partir de louis 15000 16
aujourd'hui ils sont toujours là ses
serres c'est vous qui les gérait comment
on fait il faut à la fois les protéger
mais aussi les réguler parce qu'il ya
plus de prédateurs ici naturel voilà il
ya plus prédateur en france tout au
moins dans les forêts de plaine aux
alentours de paris ça c'est certain il
ya plus de nous donc actuellement la
population de cerfs et bien elle se
reproduit et elle se reproduit avec une
certaine fréquence et on peut arriver à
un certain moment avoir un surnombre
d'un niveau dans certaines circonstances
sur l'espace rambouillet on à
3,36 euros 100 ha alors qu'en forêt
domaniale on est aux alentours de 3 0
100 hectares quel impact ça a
la proportion qui peut y avoir de serre
est un petit peu en surplus alors là non
l'impact c'est que on a défini
scientifiquement quelle forêt domaniale
de rambouillet était par exemple à un
équilibre à 3,7 pour cent hectares c'est
à dire qu'avec cette densité là il
n'apparaîtra pas de date a qu'à la
végétation qui soit véritablement
remarquable par contre à partir de
trente animaux sont hectares comme ici à
l'espace rambouillet l'impact est
particulièrement remarquable c'est à
dire que toute la végétation basse et et
manger
la régénération des arbres est bloqué
c'est à dire le moins de règlement qui
va tomber qui va germer il va être mangé
très très vite et effectivement on a on
a un blocage général de toute cette
diversité végétale alors comment est ce
que vous vous réagissez qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire alors le ce qu'il faut faire
ici c'est ne pas augmenter les dégâts
ici on ne peut rêver que les stabiliser
on est dans un nez dans un hymne
éléments où il va falloir acquérir le
public et on accueillant publique ont
été tenues si le public veut voir dsr de
maintenir cette grande densité par
contre il ne faut pas qu'elle augmente
donc ce qui va être fait chaque année
c'est un prélèvement d'un certain nombre
d'animaux de maintenir à ramener
toujours le nombre d'animaux à un
chiffre maximal un prélèvement ça veut
dire concrètement ça veut dire que si on
a la possibilité de sortir des animaux
vivants pour les relâcher ailleurs on le
ferait mais la plupart du temps c'est un
prélèvement qui se fait par le voix de
la chasse aurait dit il ya de la chasse
dans l'espace rambouillet voilà il y à
une régulation qui se fait par le biais
de l'achat
globalement ici la vision du sort c'est
quoi c'est le symbole mais aussi d'un
certain côté une menace menace non faut
pas aller jusque là le symbole oui à
partir du moment où le symbole reste
dans une clause une quotité acceptable
et là aussi bien acceptable pour la
forêt qu'acceptable pour le public c'est
ménager la chèvre et le chou c'est pas
toujours évident merci beaucoup pour
tout ces informations
entre trappe et montini la réserve
naturelle de la base de loisirs regorge
aussi d'espèces rares à protéger en
particulier les oiseaux reportage avec
julie rocha soares et jonathan willeman
voir sans être vu ce parisien a fait le
déplacement jusqu'à la réserve naturelle
de saint quentin en yvelines pour
admirer la faune et la flore
nous sommes venus me voir
admirer la nature leurs réserves et en
particulier les oiseaux chi possible
d'autres choses comme les papillons ou
des insectes parfois il ya des bons
champignons
depuis 25 ans la réserve recense plus de
500 types de végétaux et entre 20 et 30
sortes de libellules des espèces souvent
fragiles voire menacés mais ce sont
surtout les 235 variété d'oiseaux
différents observé qui la rendent unique
en ile de france en fait la réserve
naturelle est une escale de migration
elle est reconnue pour pour les oiseaux
qui sont en migration qui viennent du
sud et qui vont au nord ou qui
reviennent passe du nord au sud passe
par saint quentin en yvelines est donc
ils s'arrêtent ici sur cette énorme
siens des étangs les plus grands de
l'ile-de-france ce qu'ils peuvent pas
rater donc ils s'arrêtent en migration
certains restent l'hiver en hivernage ou
alors se reproduisent sur le site
limicoles mouette mélanocéphale
bécasseau ou encore sternes naines pour
les observer la réserve organise des
visites guidées les week-ends et sur
réservation
7000 visiteurs se promènent chaque année
sur le sentier pédagogique de plus d'un
kilomètre et demi
nous voici dans le parc régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse historiquement
c'est le premier d'île de france
puisqu'il a vu le jour en 1985 il
s'étale sur cinquante et une commune des
yvelines et de l'essonne sur une
superficie de 633 km carrés et pour
comprendre comment le protège nous avons
rendez-vous avec françois hardy
françois hardy bonjour bonjour sophy
vous êtes responsable de la mission
nature et environnement au parc c'est ça
alors le parc est tellement grand que
plus de cent mille personnes vivent à
l'intérieur un peu éparpillé comment on
fait pour gérer le fait qu'il y a des
gens dans un parc et qu' ils
interagissent avec le patrimoine oui
c'est vrai qu'il est un peu beaucoup la
surface du territoire sont mille
habitants c'est l'un des parcs de france
les plus des plus habitée donc s'il faut
faire c'est faire en sorte que ce soit
un projet de développement qui soit
compatible et qui voire même favorise la
protection de ce patrimoine naturel
c'est-à-dire comment par des actions
pédagogiques auprès des écoles auprès du
grand public des manifestations des
documentations à toute une série de
documentation
à destination des habitants ou des
touristes des promeneurs et c'est la
qualité de l'eau dans les yvelines et
pas forcément très élevé voire parfois
assez faible comment on fait pour gérer
ça au fond de la prairie là-bas dans des
études sur l'hydrologie cette fois ci on
a démontré que l'eau qui s'infiltre à
travers les plateaux après avoir être
passé dans les cultures agricoles donc
chargé un plan nitrates quand même même
si les agriculteurs font attention à ça
bien l'eau arrivant bad versant dans les
sources à plus de 50 mg de nitrates par
litre elle travaille quand elles sont et
beaucoup s'y connaissent pas qui dépasse
la norme d'eau potable de combien
2 5 6 mg france et voilà sauf que c'est
pas d'eau potable mais pour donner une
référence voilà donnons-nous normes de
comptabilité
si cette eau traverse une zone humide
donc amarré une roselière et qu'elle
ressort ensuite pour aller dans la
rivière on ne trouve plus que 20 mg en
moyenne de nitrates nouve cette petite
zone humide qu'il y a sur le bad versant
avant la rivière permet de filtrer un
véritable filtre biologique donc voilà
c'est un des services rendus par la
nature à l'homme il ya un document de la
préfecture des yvelines dès 2007 qui
pointé du doigt le parc notamment de
rambouillet disons que la biodiversité
il était en danger est-ce qu'il faut
également s'inquiéter pour le parc
national d'al ahly de
s'inquiéter il faut en être conscient
la biodiversité en dans notre parc en
île de france en france en europe elles
continuent de dégringoler donc s'il faut
faire c'est absolument en avoir
conscience et que tout le monde s'y met
c'est pas le travail du parc dont une
petite équipe
huit personnes à l'environnement c'est
le travail de toutes les communes aussi
des habitants quand je vous parlais de
diversité et de qualité de l'eau la
relation est simple les produits
herbicides par exemple vont détruire ce
sont des poisons même si les marchands
les grandes comme des produits
biologiques ce sont des biocides donc
des qui tue la vie par définition est
donc tout ça se retrouvent dans les eaux
dans les nappes et c est en tout ça dans
les prairies donc autant de biodiversité
qui disparaissent donc on essaie avec
les agriculteurs de reconstruire un peu
en faisant des petits très dépendants
herbes et des mares etc merci beaucoup
pour tout renseignement vous entrez je
vous propose maintenant de suivre un
recensement d'une des espèces que
protège le parc les chouettes chevêches
inspection des nids avec patrick jacq
des leaks monde
une paire de gants un saut de tourbe et
une échelle grégory patek fait la
tournée des nids posées par le parc à la
recherche des chouettes chevêches peu de
chance de trouver l'animal car depuis
leur installation aucun rapaces n'ai
encore jamais habité bon comme on peut
s'en douter il ya pas de feu de chevet
ch
mais ya des débris de mousse
qui indiquent qu'il y avait un couple de
maisons au moins depuis le début du
programme national de protection les
résultats ne sont pas spectaculaires peu
d'animaux utilisent ces nids de
substitution en cause l'agriculture
intensive les grandes parcelles de
cultures ont fait disparaître la plupart
des vieux arbres fruitiers son habitat
naturel les pesticides eux détruit son
garde-manger les insectes résultat le
dernier couple de chevet en habitat
naturel dans le parc s'est éteint au
début des années 90 elle avait
totalement disparu du parc historique
des 21 communes mais aller au tour donc
aller en essonne est allé dans le assez
présente dans le dans le mantois en
descendant après dans le sur granby
soudan et donc le but qu'on s'est fixés
c'est de
recréer un lien entre ces deux gros
noyau
sous le toit de cette grange un autre
nid a été installé pour les chouettes
effraies celui là et il était habité
l'année dernière par un couple qui a
laissé ses marques c'est une pelote de
réjection c'est simplement les poêler
les eaux qu'elle n'a pas pu digérer qui
régurgitent sous forme de
petite pelote comme ça alors quasi tous
les oiseaux font ça veut dire qu'il n'y
ait bien malté la pelote est très sèche
et en a qu'une ces mauvaises augures
pas de chouettes effraies non plus dans
ce nid la dame blanche comme on
l'appelle est également une espèce
protégée en plus des pesticides les axes
de circulation qu'au souvent sa mort car
l'espèce chasse souvent dans les prêts
aux abords des routes
neuf jeunes sur dix n'atteignent pas
l'âge adulte on estime entre 15000 et
25000 le nombre de chouettes effraies
qui périssent chaque année sur les
routes
c'est la fin de ce numéro d' équilibre
le dernier de la saison qui vous aura
permis j'espère de découvrir un peu plus
notre patrimoine naturel nous on se
retrouve l'année prochaine pour de
nouveaux numéros d'ici là restez curieux
la planète continue de tourner et nous
on prend le temps de l'observer
[Musique]